[Music]
now we're on the internet and the first
question goes to John Waters you love to
hitchhike do you worry about your safety
when on the road or most of your
experience is extremely positive John
tell us about this you hit sharks I'm
not gonna tell y'all but I did his like
across America nine days or didn't bull
started right out front of my door in
Baltimore and ended in front of my
apartment in San Francisco so nine days
twenty rides and it was hard getting
ready to wait eight hours I ran out of
water one day I thought do I have to
drink my own urine I mean it was not
easy but every ride was great try it
just why because I'm writing a book
about it I imagined the first part as I
imagined the worst that could happen and
then I imagined the best like two little
novels thinking up every ride and then I
actually did it and so I hid checked
when I was young and I wanted to give up
control I just want to throw everything
aside and and try it but people must
have wrecking
no they don't they all thought I was
homeless people came over to give me
money nice not when you're standing in
Kansas on an entrance rate
all right I wanted to ask about we're in
at a time is the the Queen's Jubilee I
know you have written about this and you
said to cost them a lot of money right
England well it costs any country a lot
of money when you shut down your
operations and you know to spin two days
it's probably about one percent of their
GDP as you know I am left forecast this
year are 0.4 growth in Britain I mean
because they took the whole day off yeah
those two extra days but it's what keeps
that whole island yeah listen I don't
want to be the Grinch that stole the the
Jubilee but either the fact of the
matter is you know these economies are
very vulnerable place already you know
an extra day perhaps but two days um you
know maybe it's bit accept but when you
think of why people go to England they
go to like walk across Abbey Road you
know cuz no one's ever thought of that I
mean I was there in Australia when she
was on tour she's his heart is working
as Lady gaga
believe me she changes her outfit every
day she appear it was hot out she had
all those hot pastel suits costume
changes she works hard if she had the
best line ever she said you got to see
me to believe me yeah so you're saying
she works for infinite money so you
better treat her right all weekend
GDP would soar okay what do you think of
rick scott's voter purge occurring in
florida and do you think he will comply
with the justice department demands that
he cease it immediately i mentioned that
in the model life that's pretty scary
stuff because you know whenever liberals
say obama's got it in the bag they're
not saying that so much anymore they
were telling me that three months ago i
always said well here are the reasons
why i think he could lose and one of the
big ones is well these black people are
still pissed off about that the economy
mitt romney's a businessman and that's
going to be great and then voter
suppression just cheating which is what
they do well
this is this is something that you know
I get in trouble for saying this but
this is a problem that Republicans
really have made up out of nothing there
is no serious voter fraud out there
because I mean it is theoretically
possible when you see people on the
internet do it where they get you know
they go up to the voter registration and
say oh give me Eric Holder's ballot and
then they pass it but you never see them
actually take the ballot and vote
because it's not worth it to go to jail
for a felony for one single vote so it
is absurd I mean people register like
I'm Chucky Cheese I voted voted twice
won and you got away with yeah in 1970
[Laughter]
it was outrageous
no she weren't gonna win it he was a
pioneer okay let's see the answer in
that question yes he won't he's trying
to resist the Justice Department rule
yeah but the amazing thing is the local
election officials aren't purging the
people he's saying they're supposed to
purge they are refusing to do something
they think is illegal which is really
remarkable okay would it be better if
the country just got over this notion of
American exceptionalism oh I think it
would I mean this is this is by the way
this is one reason why I say and people
laugh at me but I would say in a hundred
years this country will be Mormon
it's a stupid religion and a stupid
country they were made for each other
and I tell you
one of the things Americans are gonna
love about Mormonism when they find out
about it is that first of all Jesus an
American this is an American in
Mormonism and they love the idea that
that Mormons embrace more than anybody
that we are the SuperDuper star-spangled
best country ever and if we have any
flaw it's that we make other countries
feel bad because our awesomeness is so
overwhelming but I think we should get
over what do you think as someone who
watches this country from abroad we
people who live outside the United
States we watch all the American
television I grew up watching Dallas and
dynasty and you know this I know I
couldn't believe it I was so happy
anyway the point being that you know we
that's what we love about America but at
the same time I wish America would say
gosh what have we done wrong instead of
pointing fingers everyone else and
saying it's because the Chinese are a
liar you make me want to defend
Mormonism I gotta say I mean the the two
things so one is I do think that Mormons
face a tougher rap than anyone else
because their religion was founded
within the last 150 years by an Epsilon
man at least Moses was sincere you know
I hear you say something good about
Jesus I've never said anything bad about
Jesus I think you know thinking he still
lives is stupid but I've never something
bad about Jesus his philosophy is
fantastic you know I mean you know that
was a truly revolutionary message he had
but I think the Mormons have all of the
records of their religion in a way that
none of the ancient faiths knew out
there and I think an American
exceptionalism I think there is
something about the amend I talked about
this in the book there's something
exceptional about our relationship to
democracy the way in which we were sort
of pioneers in this that part of
American exceptionalism is true the part
that I absolutely look arrogant I don't
like but I don't like anybody who looks
at all religions are fine with me do
believe what you like just don't make me
do it and mind your own business
they sometime defect all our lives you
know like when they cause Wars and
Crusades but that's they're not minding
their own business
Zach yeah when they're causing war from
Black Knight as Susan Burke what do you
think of the federal court's ruling that
rape and sexual assault while serving in
the military must be deemed incident to
service I'm hoping that we'll be able to
overturn that ruling I do not think it
should be held to be a prerequisite when
you sign on to defend the nation you're
not signing on to be raped is that what
that means yes the district court we
have three lawsuits going district court
dismissed one holding that it was into
incident to service that it could not be
questioned at all all right and finally
I would be remiss if I didn't ask you
John about cannibalism well I know you
have a musical about it your movie it's
in one of the two of my movie I think
although maniacs and pink flamingos but
I haven't personally tried it yeah
here's that drug it's never don't and it
must be so embarrassing sit got any
Mefford on its method on stupid other
junkies would say no it's mefferd on you
but he got the speech in his head is
that what that's where they assault
nefra don't got any methadone but must
be so embarrassing to be a methadone and
then i read a thing about this other kid
that did it Minton he ripped his
testicles off and i said 'dad them what
torture me with narrative
[Applause]
okay all right we got to go thank you
everybody Thank You Pat over here Real
Time with Bill Maher ask bill and its
guests your questions right after the
show at hbo.com